well despite enacting some of the
toughest lockdown rules in the country
governor gavin newsom is
facing a surge in new covid cases across
california our next guest
calling the strict lockdowns a quote
failure of imagination
on behalf of lawmakers here to explain
is dr j batticaria
professor of medicine at stanford
university dr battacharya thanks so much
for being with us
it does seem like lockdown lockdown
lockdown it's the cure-all it's the
instinctual almost reflexive response
from policy makers tell me why that's a
failure of imagination
i mean the key thing it doesn't respect
the facts about this epidemic and about
this virus the virus spreads
in households it spreads basically
in ways that that we kind of know
whereas the lockdown sort of law sort of
suppresses society
in places where the virus doesn't
necessarily you know spread a lot uh
it also i mean it it reduces our ability
to
up to react to the to the buyer so for
instance uh we closed our schools
all that means a lot of a lot of people
with who work in front line settings
they have kids and they can't go to work
because they have to
take care of their take care of their
kids um we uh
the lockdown itself all it ever even
theoretically all it does is it delays
when the infections occur
and in a sense what's happened in
california we now bunch them up
all right now and our hospitals are
starting to get stressed as a result
i mean our hospitals are empty for large
parts of this the spring and the summer
weirdly right the the the the idea
behind lockdowns wasn't to kill the
virus it was to bend the curve that's
what we were told in early spring
so what would have been a better policy
response doctor
well we know that older people people
over 70
have a 95 survival rate from the virus 5
mortality is pretty high whereas under
70
the survival rate is 99.95 percent just
0.05 percent mortality older people are
the ones who are at risk
we should have done everything we could
possibly do to protect older order
population let me give you one failure
of failure where i think we just it's
just so obvious once you say it
there are people who are say 64 65 they
have diabetes they're actually at high
risk of mortality
and yet they're maybe they're a clerk at
a grocery store or a janitor well we
call them essential and expose them to
the virus
we should have been protecting them our
policy should have been designed to give
them
leave or or more tailored
less blunt that seems pretty obvious um
i'd like to see if i can get to two big
important stories with you really
quickly
um you brought up elderly um people in
our society who are most vulnerable
there's this emerging debate among
health experts
who should be prioritized when it comes
to the vaccine should it be older
americans or should it be used as a
chance for racial equity should we
prioritize essential workers who have
more minority populations more
represented by minority populations
should we be taking race into account
doctor
i think the key thing is if we want to
minimize mortality from this virus what
we need to do
is prioritize older people and
especially people with
chronic conditions minority populations
with
chronic conditions should be prioritized
absolutely especially older older people
i mean i think that's the key question
what do you want if you want to reduce
deaths from this virus prioritize older
populations
seems obvious really quickly because
you're from stanford i have to ask you
about the story the controversy about
stanford prioritizing
you know professors at the higher level
not front line workers what's your
response to what happened in stanford in
the vaccine distribution there
i mean i think they made a mistake uh
prioritizing people like
you know people people like me i guess
although i haven't had the vaccine as
yet
um they should have been prioritizing
people who really at the front line
especially those
who take care of older people right
really really good information a lot in
a little amount of time
dr j batacharya from stanford thanks so
much for your time this morning
thank you